where i have done really well in
language learning is when i have had
sort of dedicated time hi there steve
coffin here and today i want to talk
about productivity hacks
and language learning and remember if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you're following me on a podcast
service please leave a review it's
always appreciated
so i was thinking about productivity
because something that i saw on the web
somewhere talked about productivity
hacks and so i thought to myself well
maybe there are some
some hints there some hacks about you
know that with regard to general
productivity that can be useful for
language learning
so i googled and if you google you'll
find lots of them
and they're very similar uh basically
you know
make a to-do list uh limit distractions
uh
get enough sleep eat well i mean they're
all quite similar and
largely things that we could think up
ourselves
one of the interesting things i found
there though was a thing called the
pomodoro technique pomodoro is italian
for tomato
and the gist of that is that you should
work in 25 minute
batches and you get a little timer so
that at the end of 25 minutes you stop
whatever you're doing
get up stretch take a rest and go back
to it again
so as i looked at these i realized that
actually
none of this really applies to my form
of language learning because my form of
language learning is actually
recreational so i do it for fun whenever
i have the time
uh i'm not actually working at a job
where i have to you know
keep other distractions away
the language learning is my distraction
i enjoy doing it i can try doing it in
25 minute
batches but if i'm enjoying
reading something on the ipad i may go
on for 40 minutes or i might stop after
15. my major learning activity is just
plain listening so in a way i cheat so i
i don't i'm not sort of totally
committed because i'll listen while
exercising listen while doing the dishes
listen while in the car and that's
giving me my language learning time
however to be fair
where i have done really well in
language learning is when i have had
sort of dedicated time
so for example when i learned chinese
in a year i became
fluent enough to do
interpreting translating
uh translating newspaper articles from
chinese into english from english into
chinese i've spent more than two years
on arabic and farsi a little bit of
turkish a little bit of this and that
and i'm nowhere near as far ahead
so i thought about that where i really
developed quickly was in my ukrainian
because i went to levive and for a week
i had six hours a day of instruction
with my tutor solomia
and uh we would meet for a coffee and we
would spend three months three hours
chatting or visiting a cathedral or a
church or a
you know a cemetery or castle or
whatever it was in in la vie for a
museum
and then i'd get notes from her and i
would review them in link and we'd meet
again in the afternoon so i had six
hours
and in the case of my chinese
i had three hours a day one on one
every day and we had to talk and i had
to try to produce the language
and really what i am now doing in my
arabic and farsi
in a way is is the things that i did
away from my class listening and reading
and not in a very you know i'm not i
don't have any assignments i sort of do
what i want to do
so i thought about that i said you know
if i were to design
so ideal scenario is i go off to iran or
i go off to
egypt
and i have a teacher for three hours a
day and then i spend the rest of time
listening and reading
and going to bookstores and and
immersing myself in the environment then
after three months or six months
i will probably progress quite quickly
and i'll make friends and i'll have
opportunities to use the language and
stuff
however i'm not in a position to do that
so what's the next best thing so i
thought to myself
if i had if i could set up three hours a
day with a tutor
in arabic or persian
and so that is a commitment so and we
get like a five minute break in between
and maybe i would have three different
tutors uh which i could arrange
uh then and we would have the sessions
sort of they would be kind of like when
i toured la vie so we would either go to
different
cities in iran or different areas of
egypt or visit you know the pyramids or
visit luxor
um
in iran whatever it might be or we might
say we're going to talk about history
for a certain period of time so there
would be this sense that i am touring
the culture or the country
and of the three hours maybe one hour
would be spent on just plain the
structures of the language
one of the things i did for romanian was
i had a bunch of these patterns in
english using you know if therefore
because
uh
on the other hand like a whole bunch of
different conjunctions different verb
tenses different prepositions and then a
series of phrases patterns that
kind of get triggered by those
conjunctions or those words
or that uh typify how the different
tenses are used and so then
i hope i'm not losing you here but if i
spend one hour of the three hours
one-on-one with my tutor going through
these patterns different pattern each
time which i could then review later on
again
and then two hours touring the country
geographically or touring the country
from a cultural or historical point of
view or food or carpets or whatever it
might be
so that there would be a sort of a focus
there would be a focus of our
conversation
uh it would bring some discipline into
what i'm doing i would then have the
rest of the day
to listen and read and do other things
this was what i did with chinese it was
like six seven hours a day the problem
with that is i'm not prepared to do it
because
my wife and i enjoy golfing we enjoy
other activities we enjoy our leisurely
breakfast we enjoy so many other things
that we're doing
that i kind of have to try hard to sneak
my language learning
in there
when i was working for the canadian
government
learning mandarin that was my job they
were paying my salary so i didn't think
of doing anything else i just showed up
at nine o'clock at my school and in the
afternoon i went home and i studied and
that was my job so
obviously the degree of motivation you
know
that i had at that time was was much
stronger than what i have now
uh many of you who are learning
languages you may be either in the
dilettante mode which is what i'm in
in my persian and arabic or have been in
my other languages that i've been
learning
or if you are
in a position where you can dedicate
yourself
then my suggested productivity hack is
that you
set aside three hours a day
one-on-one with the tutor
one of the three hours is on structure
patterns that kind of thing
and two of them on discovering the
culture and the history in the country
and then in the afternoon if you have
that much time to spend on the language
spend that time listening and reading
and preparing for that next focused
uh lesson that you're going to have with
your tutor which focusing therefore
either on patterns or some aspect of of
the culture so that then brings some
structure into your learning
i think all of that would be very useful
in terms of increasing your productivity
assuming you have the time but in the
meantime you can also google
productivity hack find the pomodoro
technique and you may find some things
there that help you you know increase
your level of productivity in your
learning activities so there you have it
i hope that was useful bye for now